สวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีครับครูเรียมสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนวันนี้เรามาเจอกันในวันอะไรคะครูนิก
ในวันในวันที่ดีครับดี
ค่ะในวันที่ดีาในวันที่
ดีเป็นวันที่ดีเอ๊ะใครนะได้ยินใครพูดคำ
นี้เอ่อวันอังคารครับวันนี้วันอังคารวัน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 4 ครับอืเดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนตุลาคมอืมตคตคใช่ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
256  5 แล้วปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ครับโอเคตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูนิก
ตอนนี้ที่เมืองที่ครูนิกอยู่นะที่อเมริกา
ตอนนี้ 10 นอ๋อ 10:00
นอืมเหมือนเอ้ยใช่มยอันนั้น 10:00 นใช่
ครับ 10:00 นเรียมก็ดูนาฬิกาของตัวเอง
เหมือน
กันนาฬิกาที่ประเทศไทยก็
10 แต่ว่าเป็น 10  PM
เออใช่เวลาห่างกัน 12 ชมงจริงๆ
แล้วของที่นี่เนี่ยเวลาเวลามันจะ
เปลี่ยนน่าจะเดือนหน้าไม่เป็นไรอืคือที่
นี่เขาจะมีเหมือนปรับเาเรียกว่าปรับเป็น
ช่วงเขาจะเรียกภาษาอังกฤษเหมือนเป็น
เหมือนเป็น Daylight  Saving ก็คือจะปรับ
เวลาให้มันช้า 1 ชมงหรือเร็วขึ้น 1 ชมง
นี่แหละครุณนิจะจจำไม่ค่อยได้อ้าวเหรอคะ
แล้วมันมีปัญหากับการดูนาฬิกาแบบนี้มยถ้า
เป็นแบบนั้นมีปัญหาครับเพราะว่าเราต้อง
ปรับเองแต่ถ้าเป็นดิจิตอลเป็นตัวเลขแบบ
เนี้ย iPhone เนี่ยเขาจะปรับให้แต่
Android ไม่ปรับให้
อ๋ออือันนี้ที่คูณนิกได้ยินจากเพื่อนนะ
แต่ว่าไม่รู้ว่าตอนนี้เป็นยังไงอื
อืมเรียมก็ใช้โทรศัพท์ Android นะแต่ว่า
อยู่ที่ไทยไม่ได้มีปัญหาอืครับก็เพราะว่า
ก็ไม่ปรับคือเัแหละคือ
ในในประเทศต่างประเทศเนี่ยบางคิดว่าน่าจะ
เกินครึ่งเพราะในยุโรปก็เป็นเหมือนกัน
ยุโรปอเมริกาแล้วก็ออสเตรเลียบางเมืองเขา
จะมีไอ้วันนี้แหละเขาเรียกว่าเป็น Day
Life  Saving ก็จะมีปีละ 2 ครั้งก็คือ
ช่วงชงเข้าหน้าหนาวกับช่วงเข้าหน้าร้อน
ถ้าจำไม่ผิดอืแบบนี้นี่เองแต่ก็สะดวกสบาย
นะคะที่ iPhone ยังสามารถช่วยให้แบบไม่
ต้องปรับเวลาเลยก็แบบรู้เลยว่ากี่โมง
เพราะว่าเค้าเปลี่ยนให้เปลี่ยนให้ใช่ๆ
ครับมันก็อันนั้นคครูนิก็มองว่าเป็นข้อดี
เพราะว่าจริงๆถึงทุกวันเนี้ยก็ยังมีปัญหา
นะเพราะว่าบางคนเนี่ยคือมันไม่ใช่ทุกคน
ที่ใช้ iPhone บางไม่ใช่ทุกคนที่ใช้เค้า
เรียกว่าเหมือนเป็นสมาร์ทโฟนใช่แล้วเค้า
ก็จะต้องมาปรับเวลาเองและมีปัญหาเหมือน
กันว่าทุกวันนี้ก็มีคนที่ยังงงๆกับเวลา
ที่เป็น Daylight  Saving แบบนี้ใช่ตอน
ที่ตอนที่เรียมเรียนอยู่ที่มหาลัยตอนนั้น
เรียมก็มีโทรศัพท์ใช้แล้วนะมีใช้โทรศัพท์
แล้วแต่ก็ยังมีบางคนที่ที่ไม่ใช้โทรศัพท์
อืแล้วเวลาเพื่อนจะโทร
หาก็ต้องแบบคือโทรหาไม่ได้เจอหน้ากันก็
ต้องคุยกันก่อนว่าจะเจอกันอีกวันไหน
หึใช่ก็เลยคิดว่าเฮ้ยความจริงตอนเนี้ย
เทคโนโลยีพวกโทรศัพท์หรือว่าสิ่งต่างๆรอบ
ๆตัวเราเนี่ยมันช่วยเรามากเลยนะทำให้
ชีวิตง่ายขึ้นอืมอืจริงครับใช่ๆก็ทำให้
ชีวิตง่ายขึ้นทำอะไรสบายมากขึ้นครูนี่
เห็นด้วย
แต่ก็ไม่ได้เห็นด้วย 100% เท่าไหร่
เพราะบางคนยึดติดกับเทคโนโลยีมากอืเกินไป
แล้วกลายเป็นว่าขี้เกียจโอ๊ยยิ้มโอ๊ยิ้ม
โอ๊ยถูกไม่ไม่อยาก
ยิ้มไม่ได้ไม่ใช่
ใครครูนิกใช้อะไรบ้างครูนิกใช้เทคโนโลยี
อะไรบ้างคือนิใช้อะไรบ้างก็ก็มีโทรศัพท์
อืแล้วก็มีคอมก็คือโนตบุ๊คแล้วก็มีอะไร
อีก
เอ่อหูฟังนี่เราจะเรียกว่าเป็นเทคโนโลยี
ได้มั้ย
ก็ถ้าบูทูธบลูทธมั้ยหูฟัง bl เป็นบูทธ
เท่านั้นคือตอนนี้จะไม่ใช้ที่เป็นสายๆยาว
ๆเพราะคุนี้คิดว่ามันไม่สะดวก
อืก็คิดว่าแค่นั้นนะครับ
เพราะ
รถรถถือว่าเป็นเทคโนโลยีมยก็เป็น
นะ
คือถ้าเป็นรถที่มีแผนที่หรืออะไรที่เป็น
GPS พวกนั้นอ่ะก็แค่นี้
ครับ
ใช่มีแค่นี้ครูนิกไม่มี iPad ครูนิกคิด
ว่า iPad สำหรับครูนิกไม่จำเป็นแล้วใน
ครัวครูนิกล่ะมีเครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้าอะไรมที่
แบบทำให้ชีวิตง่ายขึ้นไม่มี
ครับอ้ามีไมโครเวฟแต่ไมโครเวฟมันก็มันใช่
มั้ย
อ่ะสำหรับคุนิใช้ก็อาจจะมีอ่ะไมโครเวฟแค่
นั้นไมโครเวฟแล้วก็เตาอบแต่คุนิมองไม่รู้
ว่ามันเป็นเทคโนโลยีหรือเปล่า
อืแต่มันก็ช่วยน่ะเนาะมันก็ช่วยแบบไม่ไม่
ต้องให้เราแบบไปแบบแบบอะไรนะหมุนก่อไฟอ่ะ
แล้วก็พอย่า
เงี้ยใช่ก็คนี้คิดว่าเก็ก็ในครัวก็จะมี
แค่นั้นครับไมโครเวฟแล้วก็แต่คุณนิก็ยัง
ชอบที่จะใช้
คือคุณนิเป็นคนชอบทำกับข้าวแล้วเวลาทำกับ
ข้าวทำอาหารเนี่ยคุณนิก็จะทำทุกอย่างบน
เตาถ้าไม่ได้เป็น
การอบขนมหรืออบเนื้ออะไรพวกเครับก็จะอัน
นั้นจะต้องใช้เตาอบละมันก็หนีไม่ได้อื
อ๋อแต่เรมว่าแบบมันอยู่รอบตัวเราอ่ะอย่าง
น้อยโทรศัพท์เครื่องนึงก็ใช้ได้เยอะแล้ว
อืมใช่แต่โทรศัพท์เนี่ยเนี่ยครูนิกจริงๆเ
ครูนิกไม่ใช่เป็นคนติดโทรศัพท์เท่าไหร่
แต่คือทุกวันนี้ที่มีอยู่เพราะว่ามันเป็น
เรื่องงานแล้วคุณนิกเก็บทุกอย่างไว้ใน
โทรศัพท์อาจจะคุณนิคิดว่ามันก็ง่ายใน
เรื่องตรงนั้นแต่ถ้าพูดถึงเมื่อก่อนเนี่ย
คุณนิกอ่ะจะไม่ค่อยอยู่กับโทรศัพท์บางที
คุณนิกไปข้างนอกไม่มีโทรศัพท์ไปด้วยก็มี
เหมือนกันอื
อืใช่แต่ในส่วนของเรมนี่คือเรมอยากจะใช้
ทุกอย่างที่เป็น
เทคโนโลยีทำไมครับหรอเรมรู้สึกว่าเออมัน
สบาย
อ่ะแบบสบายอ่ะจริงนะจริงใช่ใช่แล้ว
อะไรมีอะไรบ้างหรอมีแบบก็
มีใช้
โทรศัพท์ใช้หลอดไฟที่แบบเวลาเวลาที่เวลา
ที่เราอยู่ข้างนอกบ้านใช่มั้ยคะเรียมก็จะ
ใช้โทรศัพท์อ่ะอืตั้งเวลาเปิดไฟ
อืใช่มันสะดวกคือถ้าเกิดถ้าเกิดเป็นเมื่อ
ก่อนน่ะเราก็แบบถ้าเกิดกลับบ้านมืดๆดึกๆ
เราก็จะแบบปลั๊กไฟอยู่ไหนสวิตช์อยู่ไหน
ใช่มยตอนนี้เราอยู่นอกบ้านแล้วก็กดเปิด
ก่อนแล้วก็ให้คนอื่นคิดว่าตอนนี้มีคนอยู่
อยู่บ้านอือฮึเออหว่ามัน
สะดวกอันนั้นก็สะดวกสะดวกว่าพอที่ไทยคือ
เปิดไฟเอาไว้เค้าก็จะคิดว่าคนอยู่บ้าน
แล้วก็มันก็เป็นการกันขโมยได้ส่วนนึงอื
ใช่ๆจริงๆพูดถึงเกี่ยวกับโทรศัพท์บ้าน
บ้านที่คุณนิกอยู่ตอนนี้เนี่ยคือแฟนคุณ
นิกเค้าก็เหมือนกับตั้งเค้าเรียกว่าเป็น
ระบบนิรภัยก็คือระบบกันขโมยแล้วมันก็สั่ง
ทางโทรศัพท์ได้คือมันก็มีตัวที่กดโค้ดใน
บ้านแต่มันก็ไม่ได้จำเป็นถ้าเราอยู่ข้าง
นอกเราก็แค่กดในโทรศัพท์ได้เลยเหมือนกัน
อืมใช่แล้วบ้านบางคนหรือว่าที่ทำงานบางคน
ก็มีกล้องวงจรปิดอืมใช่มั้ยคะครับ
ใช่ก็เป็นกล้องแล้วก็เหมือนกับมีดูว่า
เอ๊ะถ้าเราไม่อยู่บ้านแล้วมีใครเข้ามาทำ
อะไรมแล้วมันก็จะเตือนเราไม่รู้ว่าคือที่
เี่มีเตือนแต่ว่าคือของที่บ้านบ้านเนี้ย
ครับมันค่อนข้าง sensitive มากบางทีแค่
เอ่อเหมือนกับมันเห็นว่ามันมีอะไรผ่านไป
เร็วๆอ่ะออมันก็จะเด้งขึ้นมาในโทรศัพท์
แล้วว่าเนี่ยมีการจับได้จับความเคลื่อน
ไหวได้อการเคลื่อนไหวใช่แล้วทีนี้คุนิกก็
มาดูแล้วมีอะไรพอเปิดไปเอ๋อแฟนคูนิวิ่งไป
เอาจดหมายแล้วก็วิ่งกลับเข้ามาแค่นั้นอื
จะได้รู้ไงเผื่อแบบวิ่งๆๆแล้วก็แบบมันมัน
อันตรายูนิกดูดูหน่อยอะไรอย่างงี้ใช่ๆเหม
ก็จะ sensitive มากอือืก็คุณนิก็มองว่า
มันก็เป็นเรื่องดีเหมือนอย่าง
ทุกวันนี้ตามแอปอย่าง netflix หรือที่เรา
ดูหนังกัน Disney  Plus อ่าถ้าในประเทศ
ไทยตอนนี้ที่มีคุณนิก็มองว่าเป็นเรื่องดี
ว่าเราก็ไม่ต้องออกไปข้างนอกไปซื้อตั๋วดู
หนังกับคนอื่นๆมันก็สบายว่าเรานอนอยู่
บ้านบ้านของเราจะนอนกินทำอะไรก็ได้เราก็
ดูหนังที่เราอยากดูได้ง่ายๆไม่ต้องไปร้าน
เช่าวิดีโอเหมือนเมื่อก่อน
อืมใช่ลืมไปแล้วอ่ะครูนิกลืมเรื่องร้าน
เช่าวิดีโอไปแล้วครูนิกเนี่ยเป็นลูกค้า
ประจำกับร้านเช่า
วิดีโอเพราะเมื่อก่อนคุณชอบดูหลังมากแล้ว
ก็คุณนิก็มองว่าตรงนั้นก็อาจจะเป็น
เทคโนโลยีที่มันง่ายว่าไม่ต้องไปเสียเวลา
ไปที่ร้านหรือหาซื้อแผ่นซีดีแล้วเพราะมัน
ทำได้ง่ายในในโทรศัพท์หรือในมือถือ
YouTube ตอนนี้ก็มีเหมือนหนังที่เรา
สามารถเช่าได้เหมือนกันหรือซื้อได้แล้ว
เขาก็เก็บเอาไว้ในบัญชีเราในาเราใช่ใช่
ใช่แล้วนอกจากนั้นเราอาจจะแบบชินแล้วก็
ได้เทคโนโลยีที่เราสามารถ
แบบโทรคุยกันหรือว่าวิดีโอคอ
อืใช่ใครจะไปเชื่อว่าจะอยู่ไกลๆกันมากๆ
เหมือนเราตอนเนี้ยเราก็ยังใช้เทคโน
เทคโนโลยีอยู่ใช่ก็เหมือนอย่างเวลาเรา
ช้อปปิ้งตอนเคูนี้คูนี้เป็นคน
ชอบช้อปปิ้ง
ออนไลน์เพราะว่าคุณนิคุณนิไม่ชอบต่อคิว
ยาวจ่ายเงินแล้วเวลาคุณนิช้อปปิ้งออนไลน์
เนี่ยคุณนิก็จะส่วนใหญ่คุณนิก็จะใช้ของ
ที่คุณนิกเคยใช้อยู่แล้วยี่ห้อที่คุณนิ
เคยซื้ออยู่แล้วคุณนิก็จะรู้ว่าขนาดมัน
เป็นยังไงเล็กไปใหญ่ไปพอดีมแล้วก็จะซื้อ
ออนไลน์เอาใช่แต่ถ้าเป็นอะไรที่ใหม่
ยี่ห้อใหม่คุนิก็จะไม่เสี่ยงไม่รู้ว่าตอน
นี้ท้องร้องแต่ไม่เป็น
ไรเกิดอะไร
ขึ้นเพราะว่าคือครูนิกเนี่ยท้องร้องเพราะ
ว่าเวลากินกาแฟเยอะๆถ้ากินกาแฟเยอะแล้ว
มันไม่มีอะไรในท้องมันเหมือนกับมันจะทำ
ให้หิวมากขึ้นอแต่เดี๋ยวเราสอนเสร็จ
เดี๋ยวคุณนิกจะไปกินข้าวอยู่ดีได้เลยค่ะ
อีกประมาณ 4-5 ชมงแค่นั้นเองชิลๆจิ๊บๆใช่
อยู่ที่ว่าเรียมจะง่วงหรือ
ยังก็ใช่คุณนิก็คิดว่าอันนั้นก็เป็น
เรื่องของเทคโนโลยีที่คุณนิมองว่ามันดี
แต่ว่าข้อเสียมันก็มีนะในความคิดคูนิครู
นิกยังติดที่บางอย่างครูนิยังอยากทำ
แบบให้มันมีส่วนร่วมกับคนจริงๆอื
อใช่หรอเหมือนเรียมเนี่ยเรียมอยากปลูกต้น
ไม้อือแต่ไม่ชอบรดน้ำต้นไม้อืเรมก็จะแบบ
เอาสปริงเกอร์เสียบไว้ครับเสียบไว้แล้วก็
ตอน 18:00 นมันก็จะแบบทำงานเอง 18:00 นก็
จะตื๊ดๆๆๆเรอืเราเก่งนะต้นไม้
โตของคุณนิกจะอ๋อเมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อนตอน
ก่อนที่จะย้ายมาที่อเมริกาครับคุณนิจะมี
ไอ้ตัวเครื่องดูดฝุ่นที่เป็นสั่งทาง
โทรศัพท์ได้ก็เหมือนกับเป็นไอ้ตัวของไอ
Robot อะไรพวกเนี้ยครับที่ว่ามันเป็น
เครื่องดูดฝุ่นอัตโนมัติคุณนิก็จะตั้ง
นาฬิกาไว้ตอนเช้าเพราะว่าคุณนิกับไม่ชอบ
กวาดบ้านเออพอคุณนิกไม่ชอบกวาดบ้านแต่
แปลกนะกวาดบ้านน่ะคุณนิกไม่ชอบคุณนี้ชอบ
ถู
บ้านคืออะไรใช่มเออเวลาแม่เมื่อก่อนนะตอน
เด็กๆแม่บอกว่าเ้ากวาดบ้านถูบ้านสิคุณนิ
ก็จะแบบบอกพี่สาวว่ากวาดบ้านให้หน่อย
เดี๋ยวูบ้าน
ให้ก็ดีนะดีนะคือแค่คุณนี้คิดว่าถูบ้าน
น่ะถูพื้นมันง่ายเพราะว่ามันก็เป็นน้ำ
จุ่มเอาไม้ถูพื้นจุ่มน้ำแล้วก็แค่ปาดๆๆ
แต่ถ้ากวาดบ้านน่ะมันเป็นฝุ่นไงบางทีเรา
กวาดแล้วฝุ่นมันก็กระจายแล้วมันก็ต้องอ้า
กระจายอีกแล้วะต้องมาเริ่มกวาดเอาให้มัน
มารวมๆกันใหม่เอออิก็เลยไม่ชอบอืตัวนี้ก็
เลยเหมือนไปซื้อไอ้ที่เป็นเครื่องดูดฝุ่น
อัตโนมัตินี่แหละแล้วตั้งเวลาเอาไว้ว่า
ให้มันทำความสะอาดก่อนครูนิดตื่นอืนี่ไง
คะอืเทคโนโลยีก็ทำให้ครูนิกสบายใช่แล้ว
มันก็ง่ายตรงที่ว่าเวลาคือเมื่อก่อนเนี่ย
ถ้าไม่จำเป็นจริงๆครุณนิก็จะไม่กวาดบ้าน
ถูบ้านอยู่บ้านคนเดียวเนี่ยคุณนิก็จะแค่
กวาดบ้านกวาดพื้นถูพื้นในห้องนอนตัวเอง
แล้วก็ในบ้านก็จะใส่รองเท้าเดินอื
แบบกำลังนึกอยู่
อืเพราะว่าคุณนิกอยู่บ้านคนเดียวไงแล้วก็
เลยโอเคไม่เป็นไรแล้วก็อาจจะกวาดบ้านจริง
ๆก็อาจจะอาทิตย์ละ 1-2 ครั้งแล้วถ้ามี
เพื่อนหรือมีใครมาบ้านก็จะทำความสะอาด
ก่อนพวกเขามาอืแต่บางตอนนี้เหมือนกับพอ
มันมีไอ้ตัวเครื่องดูดฝุ่นอัตโนมัติเนี่ย
คุณนิก็สั่งทางโทรศัพท์บอกว่าโอเคเนี่ย
ให้ตั้งเวลานี้เวลานี้นะมันก็จะทำให้อืม
อืแล้วถ้าสมมุติ
ว่ามีบางสิ่งบางอย่างเกิดขึ้นทำให้ไฟดับ
ไฟดับเลยนะประมาณ 2 วันครูนิคิดว่า
มันใช้ชีวิตยาก
มั้ยจริงๆสำหรับคุณนี้ครุณคิดว่าไม่ยาก
เลยอืมเพราะว่าพวกเทคโนโลยีที่คุณนิกใช้
เนี่ยมัน
เป็นอะไรที่ครูนิกมองว่าก็ไม่ได้สำคัญ
มากยกตัวอย่างถ้าไฟดับ 2 วันโอเคโทรศัพท์
โทรศัพท์มีแต่ว่าชาร์จแบตไม่ได้สิ่งที่
คุณนี้ทำได้ก็คือดูว่าอะไรที่เซฟไว้ในนี้
แล้วเขียนใส่
กระดาษหฉลาดมากเขียนใส่กระดาษแล้ว
ก็ถ้ามันมีอะไรที่สำหรับคุณนิคิดว่าไฟดั
ใช่แล้วโทรศัพท์ยังมีแบตเหลือไม่เยอะแล้ว
ก็จะอาจจะถ้าเกี่ยวกับงานเราก็จะติดต่อหา
คนที่ทำงานว่าเออนะมันมีปัญหาตรงนี้อาจจะ
ติดต่อไม่ได้อือถ้ามีปัญหาอะไรก็อาจจะ
ทิ้งข้อความไว้ที่ทำงานเอาไว้แล้วถ้าไปทำ
งานเจอก็จะรู้ว่าคือมีอะไรแค่นั้นอืใช่
หรือก็ไปบ้านเพื่อนไปบ้านเพื่อนแล้วก็ไป
ใช้อะไรที่จำเป็นกับบ้านเพื่อนที่มี
ไฟืใช่ค่ะถ้าเกิดแบบในกรณีที่ดับแค่บ้าน
เราหลังเดียวเราก็แบบไปชาร์จที่อื่นได้
เนาะใช่ใช่แต่ว่าถ้าเกิดดับพร้อมกันเรียม
คิดว่าถ้าไม่มีใครแบบโทรหาใครก็ไม่แปลกเ
ก็คงรู้อ่ะเก็คงรู้ใช่ว่ามันมีอะไรเกิด
ขึ้นอืแต่สำหรับคุณคุณนิกมองว่ามันก็ไม่
ได้ให้ความสำคัญกับคุณนิมากถ้าไฟดับหรือ
เราขาดเทคโนโลยีไปสักพักหรือพักใหญ่ๆอื
อืชีวิตอาจจะแบบสบายขึ้นก็ได้นะอีกแบบนึง
สบายขึ้นก็ใช่แต่มันก็มันขึ้นแบบเหมือน
กับสำหรับคูนิเนี่ยไม่มีเทคโนโลยีก็จะดี
ประมาณ 70% พอมีเทคโนโลยีก็อาจจะดีขึ้น
75% โหน้อยมากมันก็เลยไม่ได้ให้รู้สึก
ว่าสำคัญกับครูนิกมากเท่าไหร่อือืมเรียม
ก็สำหรับเรียมนะตอนนี้ยังนึกไม่ออกว่าถ้า
ไม่มีไฟฟ้าจะเป็นยังไงแต่ก็อ่านหนังสือ
ได้นะแต่แค่เออทำงานไม่ได้อาจจะเป็นชีวิต
ที่สงบสุขอีกแบบนึงที่แบบโอเคไม่มีไฟอ่าน
หนังสือไปว่ารูปอาจจะต้องกวาดพื้นอืถู
พื้นไปทำอย่างอื่นแค่นั้นเองความจริงเรา
ก็อยู่ได้แหละใช่มันก็อยู่ได้อีกอย่างที่
ครูเรียมบอกว่ามันไม่มีไฟมันไม่มีไฟเราก็
ทำอย่างอื่นตอนกลางวันก็ได้ยกตัวอย่างว่า
โอเคมันไม่มีไฟที่จะชาร์จโทรศัพท์ชาร์จ
คอมเวลาทำงานกับเอ่อพวกเครื่องใช้ไฟฟฟ้า
แต่เราก็ทำอย่างอื่นที่มันไม่ต้องใช้ไฟก็
ได้จากที่เราทำทุกอย่างทำงานผ่านคอมจดใส่
กระดาษเอาแล้วก็ถึงเวลาไฟมันกลับมาเราก็
แค่ถ้าไม่อยากจะพิมพ์ทุกอย่างเข้าคอมใหม่
ถ่ายรูปในกระดาษที่เราจดเข้าคอมก็ได้
อืวันนี้เวลาหมดแล้วค่ะดูเวลาใน
คอมพิวเตอร์หมดแล้วอ๋อคนี้มีนาฬิกาอยู่
ตรงนั้นครับอนึกว่าแบบครูนิกดูแสงแดดส่อง
เข้ามาในห้องรก็ส่องเข้ามามันแสงแดดมัน
บอกว่าตอนนี้
1022 ใช่ใช่เหมือน 22 อ๋อได้เลยค่ะต้อง
ลาไปก่อนต้องไปแล้วโอเคครับสวัสดีครับ
สวัสดีค่ะ
ครับ